I take no pleasure in being
right the world is undergoing a
tremendous rapid and violent
transformation sadly Russia's invasion
of Ukraine and the war in Israel are
almost certainly just the beginning of
what is to come if you've yet to read my
book an immigrants love letter to the
West here's what I said in the preface
over 2 years ago now when I started
writing this book in early 2021 I began
with a preface that I felt most
accurately summed up the challenge
facing the Western World when I showed
it to friends they told me it was
beautiful and well written but insisted
that I not include it because it was
melodramatic I heeded their advice
however shortly before the book went to
print in February 2022 Russian forces
invaded Ukraine I hope with all my heart
that by the time you're reading these
words the conflict has been resolved no
doubt endless articles have been written
about how and why it happened to help
people in the west deal with the shock
and surprise of the invasion there are
political e economic historic military
and even religious explanations for how
a war broke out in Europe in the 21st
century many make sense some are even
true but there is a broader theme few
commentators understand or wish to
acknowledge which is the subject of this
book and the original preface which I
include below the good Amir moam stands
in the heart of the ancient city of
samand in modern day usbekistan the
Magnificent structure known colloquially
as the Tomb of the commander was built
to preserve the remains of Taman a
terrifying conqueror who modeled himself
on genas Khan his Tombstone is inscribed
with the words when I rise from the dead
the whole world shall tremble on the
21st of June 1941 Soviet Anthropologist
opened the tomb on the orders of Joseph
Stalin and began exhuming taman's body
as the scent of Frankincense Rose camper
and resin filled the air they discovered
an additional inscription inside the
casket whoever disturbs my tomb will
will unleash an Invader more terrible
than I the following morning Adolf
Hitler's Nazi Germany invaded the Soviet
Union the history of humanity is a
series of unopen tombs which hold not
only the stories of our past but also
Stark warnings about our future as I
write this in January 2021 the West is
suffering from a global pandemic
covid-19 a virus of the body has brought
Devastation to millions of people around
the world and forced our governments
into unprecedented measures whose
consequences will become apparent in the
years to come the virus and our zealous
response have ravaged the global economy
deprived us of our civil liberties and
caused Untold damage in every area of
our lives but another devastating
epidemic has spread like wildfire
through the Western World particularly
the anglosphere and shows no signs of
abating unlike Co this is a virus of the
mind if you're fortunate enough to have
avoided social media do not work in a
progressive industry and are not a
recent graduate your awareness of this
virus may be peripheral you may not yet
be familiar with terms like critical
race Theory social justice and wokeness
I envy you but even so if you're reading
this book you've likely spotted that the
world around us is changing at
unprecedented speed you may have noticed
a dramatic change in the tone of our
public discourse nearly 2third of
Americans now say that they fear
expressing their political views
including a majority of Democrats at 52%
Independents at 59 % and Republicans at
77% in Britain nearly half of us feel
less free to speak our minds while only
20% feel more free to do so than we did
a few years ago perhaps you've watched
in confusion as men and women have been
positioned not as partners but opponents
and some kind of Battle of the Sexes it
may have struck you that our
conversations about race have become a
way to separate us rather than bring us
together you may have watched in
confusion the statues of historical
figures were defaced or torn down by
Angry mobs perhaps your employ lawyer
brought in someone to explain that being
white Imus you with some sort of
original sin or that being black or
brown makes you a victim of life you may
even have been on the right side of all
these issues for years perhaps you
thought that only bigots worry about
expressing the problematic beliefs that
men are toxic and white people should
atone for the terrible crimes of their
ancestors and their inherited privileges
in society you may have spent your life
supporting Progressive causes giving
money to charities for disadvantaged
groups and being on the right side of
history and yet as JK Rowling discovered
your belief in basic biology may be your
undoing nonetheless even if you're
fortunate enough to have avoided direct
contact with these issues you may have
noticed an odd feeling what it is you
can't explain and for now it is
relatively easy to ignore as you busy
yourself with daily life you reassure
yourself that things can only get better
and yet in those rare moments of
reflection you cannot help feeling a
sense of forboding it is hard to put
into words how you know this but someone
somewhere has opened another cursed tomb
the initial phases of operation
Barbarosa Hitler's invasion of the
Soviet Union which began on the 22nd of
June 1941 were a huge success German
armored formations which had Blitz GRE
their way through France Belgium and the
Netherlands in 1940 were now speeding
towards Moscow crushing disorganized
Soviet resistance as they went my
great-grandfather who had just returned
home from the winter war with Finland
was thrown into the meat grinder of the
Eastern Front along with millions of
others in order to stop the German
Advance like him most of them never
returned if you've ever traveled from
moscow's Shera airport into the city you
may have noticed three odd-looking metal
structures along the road these
anti-tank obstacles Mark how close the
enemy came to Tak in the city across the
entire front the Soviet Union fought for
its survival nowhere was the war more
intense than at Stalingrad Fierce
fighting in the city went went on for
months with Stalin sacrificing more and
more men and material in recognition of
a simple fact retreat was no longer an
option as the Battle of Stalingrad hung
in the balance on the 20th of December
1942 the body of tamine was returned to
his tomb and given a full Islamic burial
within days the Soviet Union mounted a
successful Counterattack at Stalingrad
and went on an offensive that would not
stop until it reached Berlin saving the
world from Nazi domination today the
fate of the Western World hangs in the
balance once again the tomb of Discord
in division has been forced open by a
small group of ideological zealots
Retreat is no longer an option either we
bury the hatchet and heal or the whole
world shall tremble once more a couple
of things before you go if you enjoy
these videos please know that they're
available much earlier on my substack so
head on over there and subscribe now do
you remember the Canadian trucker
protest in 2022 where thousands of
Canadians came out to protest Co
restrictions and vaccine mandates now
these protests lasted for weeks and the
people out on the streets needed money
as any Grassroots protest would so
people set up online crowdfunding
campaigns which raised millions of
dollars was incredible but those
campaigns were closed down and the money
didn't get to the protesters because the
Canadian authorities started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure on them to close the
campaigns the biggest crowdfunding
platform the one we've all heard of
completely capitulated to the demands
now this is where our partners gifs and
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts GI and go
came out and said they respect diverse
views and believe hope and freedom are
values worth fighting for this is why
we're proud to partner with them so if
you need to crowd fund for whatever
means the most to you then don't go to
the big Tech platforms go to give and go
starting a campaign on give and go is
easy and intuitive go to give send
go.com today that's gend go.com to start
raising money for whatever matters to
you by the way if you love this video
make sure to click on this one where I
talk about why the world makes less and
less sense every
day